he's talking about uh invariant
prediction for generalization in being
possible
great
okay um can everyone see and hear me and
see my screen
yes great all right cool um so
thanks for the introduction uh yes my
name is clara lyle
from the university of oxford i'm going
to be talking about a recent work that
we presented at icml this year
uh called invariant prediction the
variant causal prediction for black mdps
um this was joint work
with a number of really great
collaborators but in particular i'm
going to highlight amusing
who is speaking right after me at this
workshop who is co-first author on this
paper
um we have a code on github
and there is an archive link here where
you can just google invariant puzzle
prediction for block and vps and it'll
come up
so the sort of motivating problem for
this talk
is something that technically isn't rl
right so rl is all about
maximizing your reward within a single
environment um but in practice when
we're thinking about
what role reinforcement learning agents
are going to play in the world
it's a lot easier to think about the
types of environments they might face as
more like a family of mvps
um so chelsea finn sort of touched on
this after talk on metal learning
um so basically the problem that we're
thinking about
for this paper is you train your rl
agent on a couple of environments um
so like you want your mujoko agent to be
able to control the half cheetah
but you can imagine that in the real
world if you're feeding it a pixel
valued input the camera might get
jostled
so even though the physics of the world
are staying the same the data that it's
getting as input might change slightly
and ideally we would like to know that
when we deploy our agent in the real
world if someone bumps its camera
and it starts seeing a new angle that
it's never seen before it'll still be
able to execute the policy that it
learned in the training environments
um so if you apply most standard dfrl
methods that are sort of
like well known today on this type of
problem
if you don't give it like on the order
of potentially thousands of training
environments it's really going to
struggle to generalize to its new
environment which makes sense
that's we trained the rrl agent to do
really well in one environment
why would we expect it to do well on
another um but the problem is that this
happens even when the new environment
is like sort of causally equivalent to
the old environments um so in theory the
agent
should be able if it had the right
representation to
take the knowledge that it picked up in
its training environments and apply it
in its test environment
um so a very short summary of where this
talk is going to go
so our goal is that we want rl agents
that can generalize to new environments
where the underlying mdp is the same
um the way that we're going to do this
is by trying to find a representation
that maps sort of equivalent
observations from the different
environments
to the same sort of like true state in
the underlying
so the way that we're going to find this
representation is by stealing an idea
from the causal inference literature
called invariant causal prediction
and basically like because we've assumed
this extra structure of the underlying
mpp being the same
the problem becomes a lot easier than
mother or transfer learning and we're
actually able to get
in some settings really nice guarantees
so at the crux of this idea is the state
abstraction
so i'm going to quickly define a state
abstraction as basically any function
that takes the state space of your mdp
and maps it to some other space
so ideally this mapping is going to
simplify your states in some way
so it might group them together if
you're dealing with a tabular setting
or it might be a map from a high
dimensional pixel-valued observation to
a low-dimensional latent representation
in the case of a deep neural network
um but we're also going to want our
state abstraction not just to be any
arbitrary function
but to satisfy certain properties in
particular we're going to be interested
in model or elements so this is
highlighted very nicely
in lee hungley's paper towards a unified
theory of state distractions
basically a model irrelevant state of
abstraction is something
that preserves the reward and the
transition dynamics of the mvp
so we can imagine if we basically had
some sort of chain environment
where you basically dropped from s1 to
s6 and then get some rewarded s6
we can sort of group together states
that are at the same level horizontally
and still preserve the transition
dynamics and the reward structure of the
mvp
um in dprl the case becomes a little bit
more complicated
and i'll mention it here because this is
the deeper element shot
so the canonical state attraction model
says we have some
input space x that gets fed into some
state abstraction phi and on top of phi
we're going to learn
some value function v
the problem is that in dprl we have some
neural network that's our function
approximator
and a neural network you can think of is
basically a sequence of compositions of
functions
so there isn't really a canonical layer
where you can say yes at lara k
i have stopped being my representation
and now everything after this is
computing my value function approximator
um so basically when you see later on
our results
for the deep learning setting and
learning representation and deep
learning
um we're basically going to sort of
arbitrarily fix some layer of the neural
network
and we're going to call that layer the
representation and that's the layer that
we're going to be feeding in auxiliary
losses too
um so the second part of this setup is
really about
okay so now we know what like a good
space distraction is how do we define
behavioral equivalence
um so ideally we would go into sort of
like the definition of sort of by
similarity
which is like the sort of more rigorous
way of defining behavioral equivalence
you can also sort of characterize it in
terms of state abstractions by basically
saying
our family of mdps are going to be
behaviorally equivalent
if there exists some state abstraction
phi
such that the image of each state space
under phi is the same
and if we look at phi over the union of
all of these mvps
it's a model irrelevant state
abstraction
so our goal here is basically to
hopefully learn phi
from a relatively small subset of all
the possible environments
technically i've written out m1 through
mk here maybe
we actually have an infinite set of
environments um in which case we
definitely
need a very small subset of the
environments to be able to generalize
well
so an example might be if you're
training a robot to do your dishes
you do a redecoration of your kitchen
but
you leave everything in the same place
you just change the wall and the
cupboard colors
you ideally don't want every time you
repaint your kitchen you're about to
have to learn how to wash the dishes
from scratch
um so we definitely want like sample
efficiency in context
like this for another example you could
think about
sort of a board game playing agent um so
maybe you want
to figure out how to map different chess
boards to the same sort of true board
state
um so you would want your starting
position in all of your different
sort of different chess pieces to map to
the same
late representation um but in particular
because
we're doing this relatively strict
assumption on
the behavioral equivalence of the
different environments
we're not really going to care too much
what happens if we try to apply this
state of attraction to
some new environment that isn't
behaviorally equivalent to the old
environments
um so like if we took our representation
that works really well for chess
and try to feed it backgammon board
through it um we don't mind if the
representation that we get as a result
is totally nonsensical
um because we're not really evaluating
ourselves on that setting
um so to understand how we're going to
find these state abstractions
it helps to think about the rl problem
as sort of a causal graphical model
so causal graphical model is basically
you have nodes and you have edges
and edges indicate indicate sort of
conditional dependence
um sort of directed in time um so like
if i change
st that affects st plus one
so the idea here is this is pretty much
the familiar rl problem
we have actions that affect your next
date
that affects your reward then you have
your next action
and then your previous date feeds into
your next state along with the action
um and you get a reward you keep on
doing that
the key observation that we're making
here is we're sort of distinguishing
the true state into what we're going to
call a causal component
and a spurious component so this is
basically saying
any component of the state that is going
to affect the reward at some point in
time
we're plugging into s everything that
sort of random noise we're plugging into
eta
so eta can be correlated over time but
it's sort of
independent of the reward so there's no
way of like following arrows
from a to t to get to r t prime for any
t
prime
so we're going to sort of take this
insight that we have that basically
we can view the oh sorry um one
important thing as well
is that we can sort of therefore like in
the framework of model or relevance to
distractions
say okay well then basically like
st is sort of determining the reward and
the tren the important transition
dynamics of the
mvp and a to t we can sort of change and
have it be whatever
so in our context we're basically
loading all of the changes between the
environments into a to t
and saying we can basically ignore this
um we really care about st
um so basically finding a good model
relevancy abstraction we can sort of
think is basically trying to figure out
what is st
so to do that we're going to use a tool
from the causal inference world
called invariant causal prediction and
this is
basically a method that takes data from
a bunch of different environments
where each environment is generated by
intervene intervening on the data
generating process in some way
and gives you a sort of set of variables
that it thinks are causal parents of the
thing you're trying to predict
so the key insight that they make is
basically this equivalence between
causality and invariance
so if i'm trying to predict some
variables say i'm trying to predict the
reward
and i'm trying to predict it using
another variable
say ada that is not a causal parent of
the reward
then if i intervene on ada the
relationship that i learned
initially between ada and r isn't going
to hold anymore
so basically i'm going to see that the
distribution of errors that i get
from one environment to the other is
going to change
so basically that change is sort of the
idea of like the invariance principle
so if i were depending on the parents
then i would be invariant to these
interventions
whereas if i'm depending on something
that isn't apparent then
i sort of will not be invariant under
these interventions
um so to sort of give like an intuitive
example
if our state just has two components x1
and x2
and x1 is the only component that will
ever affect the reward
then if we sort of initially train a
value function predictor on x1 and x2
we might not necessarily assign value 0
to x2
it's super unlikely that our
optimization procedure exactly assigns
like zero reward if we were doing
something like linear regression
um so basically what we can do instead
is say okay well now let's train on two
environments
i'm going to assume that in the second
environment there was like some sort of
intervention on this distribution
so maybe i fixed x2 to be something
now the relationship between x2 and the
reward
is going to change so the error that i
was getting in environment one
is going to be very different from the
area that my predictor now gets the
environment to
and this is basically the procedure that
invariant causal prediction uses to
identify fossil parents
so we make sort of one assumption that
is
a little bit stronger than normal markov
assumption in rl
so normally the markov assumption in rl
says
x1 and x2 t are independent of
1 and x 2 sort of t minus k
given x 1 and x 2 t minus 1. um we're
going to assume something slightly
stronger
which is basically that if you have
sort of two very if we have x one t
and x two t uh then they're
conditionally independent of each other
given x one t minus one and x two t
minus one so basically this is just
saying that there's no like hidden
mechanism
generating our mdp that's like
correlating them beyond whatever
they would get from the previous date
and the second assumption we make is
that training environments correspond to
interventions on variables
so the main takeaways are
sort of number one that the which we've
hinted at already
is that the sort of causal component of
your state
corresponds to a model irrelevant state
attraction and in particular
if your state corresponds to the set of
variables
in the causal graph that's sort of
responsible for your mdp
then just taking the subset of the
indices that correspond
to the causal variables is basically
enough to give you a model relevant
state abstraction in namdp that's now
generated by interventions on ada
so this is really nice because it
basically means that we can directly
apply
the icp algorithm to the rl setting to
find a state abstraction that's sort of
going to generalize
basically perfectly to any other mdp in
our family
assuming that we had sufficient training
environments and
in certain settings like if the
transition dynamics are linear with
gasoline noise
then we basically need on the order of
the dimension of
the state training environments to
identify the causal ancestor
so this is way better than what you
would get if you didn't have this
assumption on the equivalence
because now we basically can say okay
well because i know that any environment
i'm going to see in the future
is related to these environments in this
very specific way
then basically once i've identified the
causal variables i'm done
so we've turned a problem of learning
into a problem of identifiability
which is much more sample efficient um
in the rich observation setting
running a bit low on time so we won't be
able to go super in-depth here
but basically we can't get really
guarantees anymore
but we can sort of take the intuition
behind this invariant fiction idea
and try to apply it to our
representation so
basically we take some sort of
representation model phi
um and on top of it we're going to be
training something like soft factory
critic or dqn
but we're also going to have this
auxiliary model
um which is sort of trying to get phi to
be a model irrelevancy distraction
that's invariant across the different
training environments and we're going to
hope that by forcing it to be invariant
across the different training
environments
it's going to sort of be picking up on
the causal structure that we want
so basically the key components of this
model are
we have a reward loss that's basically
telling us okay we need to capture the
reward
we have a transition dynamics loss
that's telling us we need to capture the
transition dynamics
um here we sort of split things up so we
could have had a transition dynamics
model
on just the sort of latent space
but the problem there is that you can
get these like weird sort of like
pathological solutions where you just
map everything to zero
um so we instead decided to basically
have this grounding in the real world
where we sort of have an additional
model that can sort of take over all the
environment specific information that
might be needed by the decoder
and then finally we're also sort of
doing adversarial domain classification
on the representation learned by the
invariant encoder to basically say
that the representations in latent space
of each of our environments
should overlap as much as possible
um so empirically we do find that this
works pretty well
um i am running very short on time so
i'll keep this like
relatively brief but basically um we
compare against sort of
two ablations so the question that we
really want to answer here is is like
the thing that is making us generalize
the invariance or is it just that we
happen to come up with a really good
auxiliary loss
um and basically what we find is so if
we just train
our model with a single decoder which is
basically
exactly this but now
instead of having sort of test specific
information we're letting the invariant
model
pick up some task specific information
um
then we see like much worse worse
generalization
if we only train on one environment it's
even worse um so this is in a really
simple
sort of model learning task where you're
just trying to predict the next state
of an agent interacting with the mvp um
we also
as a sanity check compared against irm
uh irm
invariant risk minimization is sort of
another approach to invariant causal
prediction
um it was targeted more at the
supervised setting when it was proposed
and we found that it was very difficult
to find hyper parameters
that would sort of make it work so in a
lot of the settings that we tried it in
it just
like didn't really converge to anything
very competitive
we also evaluated model learning for a
linear predictor
in the setting where our theory tells us
we should perfectly learn
the right state abstraction and we find
that indeed basically
as we intervene on different variables
in the mdp
as we intervene on this race variables
in the mdp we find that
a predictor that's trained on the icp
representation
basically it doesn't matter how far you
push the various variables away from the
training distribution
it still predicts perfectly well um but
a model that was just trained on the
full state space
using a least squares predictor uh does
quite
terribly as you shift the input
distribution further from the training
distribution
um so we basically repeat a similar
experiment for imitation learning
so in this experiment we were varying
the background color
um so we train with two different
background colors and we evaluate on a
third
here we train on two different camera
angles so this is basically
the mujoko half cheetah with different
camera angles from the first slide of
this presentation
um and we find again basically that
enforcing with some variants
really helps reduce your generalization
although
we note that we do still see overfitting
um which kind of makes sense in the
setting because
trying to sort of be in variance to all
possible camera angles you've already
only drawn
two is a pretty difficult task
and finally we look at the reinforcement
learning setting uh
wrapping up now don't worry um so we
basically see again
uh training with this like invariant
representation
you get a much smaller generalization
gap than you do if you just change
a regular zap model um right so in
conclusion we've
basically shown that invariant
prediction is super useful for finding
state distractions that can help you
generalize new environments
um we've shown some results on how to
find these state distractions and how
they generalize
and we've shown in the rich observation
setting that just trying to get your
representation to be more invariant
uh improves your performance on new
environments tasks
all right thank you all and i'm happy to
answer any questions
yeah excellent thanks um yeah
so we have a time for questions um and
questions from the audience
um well maybe i can start with a
question um perhaps i
am missing some details um technical
details
but i i'm curious what um whether
this work it's somehow compares to
an earlier work by peter stone's team
in about i forgot the time 2000
something
with nick john on predicting irrelevant
state variables using
various kind of hypothesis testing um
the setting is that you have a long
state vector and you want to discover
which ones are relevant which one are
not they use some kind of hypothesis
testing to
identify which ones are relevant is it
somehow related and have you
yet do you say something about it yeah
so i haven't read that paper so i can't
say
a lot about it i will say that that's
sort of effectively exactly what our
method for
the sort of like exact observable
variable setting is doing
um we're basically i guess the trick
here is that
we sort of are leveraging the multiple
environments so rather than just saying
in a single environment we're testing
whether sort of this variable is
independent of the real world
um we're really sort of looking over
like all of these environments
um we're doing a hypothesis testing on
the induced distribution
of errors like predicting the return um
but
it's it sounds quite similar it's like
the same idea before it just sounds like
a difference of like
are you looking at multiple environments
where are you looking at the single
environment
okay nice
and then i i noticed that you have an
assumption in assumption one if i
remember um in the talk that says um you
require the uh
the observation to be fully markovian
right yeah it's fully observable and
therefore it's i'm accordion
um is there um have you thought uh have
you
tried at least empirically to see how
sensitive the approach is
when this assumption is slightly
violated
uh so i think um like in principle
it should still work like this method
would work in theory
i think um under some settings of
partial observability
uh the main thing that we were really
trying to avoid
um with assumption one is sort of there
being hidden variables
that are sort of affecting this like t
minus one to t
of like these sort of like different
indices
of your state um so basically
icp does in theory sort of i think you
can sort of get it to work
with like some hidden variables so in
theory it should also work
uh in settings where you're starting to
sort of have like upon dp
um but we were mostly it's a lot easier
to do the analysis
when you assume you can observe
everything so for our purposes we just
sort of
assumed like a standard rl setting
right yeah this is a super interesting
area for future work
sure yeah yeah i um yeah so
i noticed that uh trava also mentioned
something
in the chat uh uh tom big switches some
has also worked on this rather than
state variable detection
in real yeah that's
yeah so this is super related um the
question that we're really interested in
is sort of like finding relevant
variables that you couldn't find in the
single environment setting
um and sort of like really trying to get
rid of those
um but yeah it's like very similar
yeah right um
so there's a discussion on the panel to
uh trying to locate what paper it is uh
achara do you remember which paper
no i need to look it up okay yep
no problem thanks um
and then uh we have a question from the
audience
could you see the qa tab uh
yes um i'm clicking on it but it's not
doing anything
oh uh great um so the question is um
as for claire so correct me if i'm wrong
for one of the
ablations cases this is done for the
model free settings
and the castle bounds are used for a
prior ride for the basin settings
um so
in so none of these cases are
necessarily basic
um i think i guess the question you're
sort of getting at is
sort of what's the actually yeah i'm not
quite sure if i follow the question
um
so basically in all of these cases we're
doing sort of frequent test hypothesis
testing
the main difference is it's a lot easier
to sort of
learn um like use the sort of like model
learning loss
rather than just trying to do sort of
like
the type of algorithm like trying to
immediately translate the type of
algorithm we have
in the fully observable variable setting
in the rich observation setting
so for us we just found it a lot more
stable to basically
try to use a model learning task as the
auxiliary task that we are trying to
sort of enforce invariance through
i hope that sort of answered the
question
[Music]
i have a quick question if there's time
uh hi claire um so
it seems i wonder in practice on a lot
of problems are you actually going to
find
things do you think that are completely
irrelevant
um or do you think that there's sort of
a more complex factored structure
where um you know maybe there's like
three different sources of reward
essentially and you know some variables
are
sort of uh irrelevant for some of them
but not for others
and you can't really make much progress
without sort of factoring and separating
those
and or do you have any thoughts about
how to do that or have you thought about
that
yeah so i think that's super interesting
is sort of getting at like because
ideally
what this work is sort of doing is
saying like in an ideal world
we would be able to sort of learn some
sparse factor graph that's like
corresponding to
the sort of true causal structure of the
world but that's really hard to do
i don't know if anyone who's succeeded
in doing that yet um so let's just sort
of
assume that like if we got a bunch of
different data from different
environments
um and we sort of learned something that
is like sort of ignoring the differences
between those environments
then it's going to similarly ignore the
differences in new environments
that sort of exhibit similar structure
um i think there's like loads of
examples in the real world where there
are components of your state that you
just want to completely ignore
um so like a bunch of stuff about like
how your data is collected right so like
the camera angle
you like really don't want to depend on
the like you can basically throw away
the camera angle once you've sort of
captured the location of all of your
limbs
um so i think like to some extent it's
safe to ignore like
most of the factors or like a lot of the
factors that vary between your
environments
um and yeah i think you can come up with
like a decent number of like
realistic-ish examples
where that works um or at least the
information that you throw away
is like less helpful than the
generalization performance that you gain
by throwing over that information
cool thanks
terrific um so it seems that we're right
on time to
uh move to the next talk if there's no
more question
um then our next speaker is amy john
from
mila amy could you share your